apple crime yaghoub chercheur associé au
groupe afrique de l'institut prospective
sécurité en europe a décliné au bonjour
et merci d'être heures en direct avec
nous sur rt france à leur première
question
on a l'impression que cette arrestation
doussain de son co a en quelque sorte
libérer la population de l'exaspération
dans laquelle elle vit depuis plusieurs
années c'est un sentiment de colère
aujourd'hui qui gagne la rue au sénégal
en effet c'est le bookbook à déborder la
vase
on a vu que la population sont
montréalaise est à bout à bout à cause
même du service des mesures dues au coup
vide parce que la population ne pourrait
plus la tension était vive
mais ce n'est pas seulement à cause de
ça ces tensions - de claix bien que ces
manoeuvres ce qui est ainsi passé en ce
moment date de longue date
on a vu tous les jeunes leaders qui ont
émergé des puits de dia jusqu'à
maintenant on va très bien que le
pouvoir en place
enfin toujours cette pression ou essayer
de mettre en difficulté ou écarter les
opposants politiques potentiels afin de
pouvoir les empêcher ou à se présenter à
des élections ou à avoir une légitimité
cela montre pendant les dernières
élections on a vu l'affairé seigle le
maire de dakar on a vu l'histoire aussi
des caries mois en a toujours eu mais le
lâcher ce qui se passe en ce moment avec
son coup c'est encore mieux parce que
son coût hors système
c'est quelqu'un quand on regarde son
parcours la jeunesse qui sort
aujourd'hui de façon simultanée partout
à dakar une jeunesse qui est déconnecté
de tout ce qui est politique mais qui
demande qui réclame vraiment la liberté
la démocratie une jeunesse qui veut des
personnes qui leur semble le fait
convoquer son cours et de l'arrêter
lever son immunité ou cela cette
facilité par lequel un leader politique
peut-être trenet ou arrêtez de cette
fois
on montre très bien que son usage
disproportionné de la force c'est un
usage disproportionné des institutions
de la république sénégalaise et ça donne
une vraie image très inquiétante du
sénégal le sénégal étant un modèle un
modèle en termes de liberté est en train
de montrer que ya des dérives
potentielles qui entonne ses dérives et
ses tirs alors j'entends bien on voit
beaucoup de jeunes ont participé à cette
mobilisation
ils ont un sentiment envers avec macky
sall qu'il refuse le président ils sont
là y le il le conteste
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on reproche
justement au président assez égal et
précisément aujourd'hui on n'a fait que
le problème de limitation des mandats
mathieson ne s'est pas clairement
prononcée sur son intention de respecter
cette limitation des mandats ou de
pouvoir se présenter à un troisième
mandat
en changeant la constitution ou en
s'imposant c'est la inquiète parce que
quand on regarde notre verdict
on voit très bien que beaucoup des
présidents africains à la dernière
minute arrive à changer la constitution
pour repérer ses prévisions au pouvoir
on a vu aussi par exemple ce qui s'est
passé en guinée la jeunesse guinéenne se
mobiliser pour refuser ce troisième
mandat même ça s'est réalisé par la
force
et ça il ya eu beaucoup de morts on a vu
comment nos candidats le jeune bobby
vannes oc s'est imposé mais on a des cas
et on a vu au tchad des jeunes leaders
comme master qui émergent et connaissait
tous des frais car cette céréale bol et
cette inquiétude quand on lit aussi la
presse on va traîner tout le monde
s'inquiète de ce qui se passe ailleurs
que le sénégal tombe aussi dans ce
système que toute l'afrique rejette ces
expressions d'inquiétude de voir le
sénégal région dans le club de ses états
dirigée par des personnes qui s'accroche
au pouvoir et cela ne ressemble pas ni à
la jurassienne et galettes à la
population à l'histoire du sénégal a
justement hier soir le secrétaire
général de
num antonio gutiérrez s'est dit très
préoccupé il appelle à éviter une
escalade est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut se retrouver justement dans un cas
similaire c'est à dire plus de violences
dans l'est dans les prochains jours et
ce que la jeunesse sénégalaise est prête
justement à manifester à se rebeller
contre le pouvoir
la jeunesse italienne la jeunesse
sénégalaise à 12e montrer de quoi elle
est capable
quand ward a voulu changer les choses
en 2011 la jeunesse s'est mobilisée et
la jeunesse a fait changer la donne
cette jeunesse sénégalaise est une
jeunesse est à l'image de la cdu
nouvelles générations africaines où les
discours les anciens du secours ne tient
plus le discours de dire que voilà en
service au pouvoir en charge des
institutions ça ne marchait plus cette
jeunesse veut imposer son avenir cette
jeunesse veut imposer son choix et cette
jeunesse veut aussi participer
politiquement aujourd'hui quand on
regarde l'âge youthman cenco 60 au
repentir d'inès donc finalement on se
retrouve face à une génération qui veut
porter aux affaires une personne qui le
comprend une personne qui comprend les
enjeux de la jeunesse africaine
sénégalaise income une personne qui des
récentes une personne qui qui se battra
pour cette jeunesse orient n'accepte pas
aussi à cette jeunesse n'accepte pas à
chaque fois de voir ces candidats jeunes
ambitieux qui ont des visions se faire
écarter d'une manière ou d'une autre
tout montre que dans tout cas quand on
voit comment les autres candidats dans
le passé se sont fait écartées ou
éliminer ou disqualifier
eh bien c'est la même logique et séries
quand elle s'est réalisée
je crois que c'est une réaction pour
l'illustrer stop à cette manipulation
stop assez
cette façon de faire pour sauver la
démocratie sénégalaise parce que même le
président macky sall a est l'intérêt
d'aller vers l'apaisement d'aller vers
vraiment d'apaiser la situation et
appelé tout le monde vers
le calme retirer ses forces libres et
ceux qui ont été arrêtés et laisser la
justice sénégalaise faire son travail
sans interférer merci pour ce qui est de
faire la liberté l'indépendance dé la
justice sénégalaise est en jeu si ça
continue comme ça
merci beaucoup a décrit now d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé au groupe
afrique de lips l'institut prospective
sécurité en europe